[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
parlement hebdo l'émission qui revient
sur les temps forts du parlement à
l'assemblée et au sénat nous sommes très
heureuses cette semaine avec tam tran
huy de recevoir loïc hervé bonjour et
bienvenue et cette âme qui dresse votre
portrait bonjour loïc hervé vous êtes
sénateur union centriste de la
haute-savoie membre de la commission des
lois vous allez avoir du pain sur la
planche puisque vous êtes co rapporteur
de la proposition de loi sur la sécurité
globale et de son article 24 qui fait
couler déjà beaucoup d'encre alors on va
en parler bien sûr tout à l'heure sinon
vous êtes entré à 34 ans au sénat en
2014 ou faisait alors partie des
benjamins de cette assemblée
vous venez d'être réélu en septembre
dernier et votre fief c'est donc la
haute-savoie limitrophes de la suisse
alors est-ce que vous irez skier chez
vos voisins à noël j'ai pas le sens de
la provocation donc nous on est là parce
qu'ils en suisse à noël en revanche j'ai
du mal à comprendre ses décisions qui
ont été prises et annoncées à
l'emporte-pièce parce que dans l'union
européenne dans l'espace économique
européen y compris que nos voisins
étaient amis suisses le principe de la
libre-circulation existe et nos liens
avec les suisses ne sont pas que des
liens économiques sont des liens de
famille sont des liens d'amitié et donc
français d'une vallée à l'autre mais la
frontière oui effectivement passe on
passe d'une c'est le même territoire
c'est la même fiabilité puisque nous
nous avons décidé de fermer les stations
pour des raisons sanitaires
alors nous n'avons pas fermé les
stations les stations françaises restent
ouvertes ce sont les remontées
mécaniques qui seront fermés d'ailleurs
il ya un contentieux au conseil d'état
qui a été introduit par un certain
nombre d'élus locaux et je le comprends
vous comprenez mais l'événement fait pas
partie de ces élus locaux nom de ce
contentieux
non parce que ce sont des
des chefs d'exécutifs c'est le présent
de la région ce sont des maires des
présidents de conseils départementaux
qui du coup je pense qu'on n'aurait plus
on aurait plutôt dû appliquer le
protocole sanitaire travail et que les
professionnels de la montagne et
regarder de quelle manière
l'ouverture raisonnable des remontées
mécaniques étaient possibles la tour
eiffel ouvre le 16 décembre les tgv
conduiront notamment les parisiens les
jambes à la tour eiffel
oui sauf que est-ce que c'est l'argument
combien d'admission de savoir combien
d'admission en réa ou en soins intensifs
suite à des accidents de ski 95% de la
traumatologie et traitées en cabinet en
montagne il ya quelques cas graves est
effectivement nécessitent des opérations
et des hospitalisations de quelques
jours ça représente 5 % de la charge de
spécialisation et si cette question est
posée
regardons commencer comment est ce
possible d'accueillir les touristes et
d'ailleurs y aura des touristes il y
aura des vacanciers il y aura des
propriétaires qui rompt dans l'eure dans
leurs biens en haute savoie
ça n'est pas interdit allez on va voir
maintenant les thèmes de cette rémission
à l'oeil qu'hervé crise politique et
institutionnelle autour de l'article 24
de la proposition de loi sur la sécurité
globale alors que les députés lrm ont
annoncé une récré tueur total le sénat a
lui rappelé que la rédaction lui
revenait de droit la commission denquête
qu'ovide à l'assemblée remette un
rapport accablant pour le gouvernement
les députés de la république en marche
ont refusé de le voter
enfin on reviendra sur le bilan
parlementaire de valéry giscard
d'estaing grand défenseur du bicamérisme
il a donné lors de son septennat plus de
pouvoir aux oppositions
et pour commencer la polémique et les
pilotes autour de la proposition de loi
sur la sécurité globale
[Musique]
l'annnonce de la réécriture du
controversé article 24 de la proposition
de loi sur la sécurité globale par
l'assemblée a provoqué l'ire de gérard
larcher le président de la république a
dû intervenir pour mettre fin à une
crise politique et institutionnelle elle
à mon égard à la crise politique
déclenchée par l'annoncé d'une
commission chargée de réécrire le temps
compté ses articles 24 lundi les députés
de la majorité espère avoir trouvé une
porte de sortie
nous allons proposer une nouvelle
écriture de l'article 24
c'est à nous à nous législateurs de
proposer rapidement cette nouvelle
réversion exit donc la commission ce
seront bien les députés qui tiendront la
pluie alors le parlement à la majorité a
repris ses droits
nous devons remettre le chantier sur l'
ouvrage
mais en voulant éteindre l'incendié à
l'assemblée nationale la majorité ouvre
un nouveau front au sénat cette fois car
la proposition de loi sur la sécurité de
l'eau bâle a bel et bien quitté le
palais bourbon pour rejoindre celui du
luxembourg
d'où ce rappel à l'ordre du premier les
sénateurs je dois donc rappeler au
groupe de la majorité de l'assemblée
nationale que la proposition loi dont il
souhaite travailler à la réécriture
partiel a été transmise au sénat depuis
le mardi 24 novembre dernier après que
les députés les adopter il revient donc
au sénat et à lui seul de l'examiner de
réécrire si cela s'avère nécessaire
mercredi nouvelle tentative d'apaisement
par le chef de l'état lui même
emmanuel macron a convié le président
larcher les présidents des groupes
politiques du sénat
il leur a réassuré son attachement au
bicamérisme loïc hervé comment le
sénateur que vous êtes at il pris la
création d'une commission qu'a annoncé
jean castex pour réécrire cet article 24
avec beaucoup d'interrogations sur la
manière
le premier ministre considère
l'application de la constitution du 14
58 ou le parlement vote la loi parlement
c'est l'assemblée nationale et celle
sénat et donc j'ai été très surpris de
cette de cette annonce alors certes on
est dans une crise politique le mot le
monde des journalistes de plusieurs
manifestations importantes dans le pays
on sont montés au créneau contre
certains tarifs 24 est d'ailleurs contre
le projet de loi
plus généralement parce que il faut pas
faut pas non plus occulter qui a tout un
projet de loi complet c'est vrai que
c'est une méconnaissance du parlement
donc c'est une tentative
c'est une tentative malheureuse de
sortir d'un faux pas mais comme la part
de rappeler présent du sénat nous aurons
le temps nous avons mais nous avons le
texte déjà dire que vous marchiez dos
reis et moi même sommes co rapporteur de
ce texte de loi nous avons déjà commencé
nos auditions et nous avons déjà
commencé à réfléchir sur une nouvelle
rédaction de l'article 24 ans qui longe
dire c'est superfétatoire est ce que
vous estimez que vous allez pouvoir
travailler vraiment normalement sur ce
texte que vous faites confiance à
emmanuel macron qui donc l'a promis aux
sénateurs alors d'un déjeuner cette
semaine moi je crois que le rôle du
sénat mais c'est valable pour ce
problème là comme pour d'autres
pour lui ce n'est de faire retomber la
pression donc j'entends ce que prétend
la république a pu a pu dire au
président du sénat aux présentes groupe
qu'il a réuni mercredi
maintenant on est au travail et on va
faire en sorte de de manière sereine
d'aborder ce texte de loi dans son
ensemble
l'article 24 en particulier 16 ans et
quand vous allez abordez-vous cette
preuve cette proposition leur mois de
janvier et la commission des lois de
l'assemblée nationale a dit qu'elle se
donnait 15 jours elle pour réécrire
l'article 24
ça veut dire que vous pensez que ça va
arriver par amendement gouvernemental
lors de l'examen au sénat vous voyez les
choses arriver comme en ont mais que
tout le monde puisse contribuer à ce
débat c'est magnifique
le sénat tient la plume si les députés
mais la proposition est bien le
rapporteur au sénat analyseront les
propositions des députés de christophe
castaner d'olivier belge de patrick
mignola ceux des parlementaires que je
connais par ailleurs écouté la
démocratie c'est aussi la position que
céline et auvergne mental vous le
prendriez mal ou pas mais l'amendement
août pergaud gouvernementale s'il est
bon il sera à voter s'il est pas beau et
ce rallye sera rejetée par le sénat je
ne me pose même pas la question en ces
termes on évoque trois présidents de
groupe de la majorité à l'assemblée
nationale qui disent on va proposer une
nouvelle rédaction
donc si si la nouvelle rédaction des
trois groupes de la majorité
parlementaire arrivent par voie
gouvernementale alors là il ya un autre
problème institutionnel sert que pour le
coup c'est un mélange des genres qui
continueraient donc pour vous il peut
pas y avoir d'amendement gouvernemental
il peut y avoir un groupe de hip hop
ailleurs un amendement du dpi au sénat
oui il peut y avoir aussi un un moment
dé rabat un amendement du rapporteur est
bien plein de choses qui peuvent se
passer
d'ailleurs concerné même pas sûr que ce
texte arrive enfin l'envié on parle
maintenant du mois de mars oui on peut
vraiment avoir un dérapage aussi mais
qui peut qui peut servir d'ailleurs à un
moyen terme à trouver pour cette
rédaction de leur fille 24
justement vous avez entamé votre travaux
et vos auditions avec votre corps à
porter à marc philippe daubresse qui est
ce que vous entendez auditionné
notamment sur cet article 24
alors on vous entendre tous ceux qui ont
quelque chose à dire sur cet article le
même cas de la conférence des procureurs
les directions du ministre à la justice
ou le ministère de l'intérieur
des universitaires tout un tas de
personnes qui peuvent alors quelque
chose d'intéressant à nous dire et
surtout à proposer une rédaction et
mieux caler juridiquement pour vous
aujourd'hui de façon claire d'abord est
ce que l'article est utile est ce que
l'article protège tout le monde on parle
des gendarmes et des policiers
est ce que demain un instituteur un élu
local
un magistrat sera de la même manière
protégée par cet article est-ce qu'il
est au bon endroit
est-ce qu'il faut toucher à la loi de
1881 ou est ce qu'il faut le mettre en
dur dans le code pénal
est ce que en le mettant dans le code
pénal
on ne crée pas un renforcement des
sanctions à l'égard des auteurs qui
serait peut-être trop importante par
rapport pour l'important par rapport à
l'objectif que l'on veut atteindre fin
toutes les questions qu'on se pose avec
marc philippe daubresse qu'on se pose
ouvertement qu'ils sont des questions
qui sont sur la table on est éclairé par
tous ceux qui ont quelque chose à nous à
nous expliquer et donc on fait
simplement notre travail de deux
parlementaires
commencez pas à dire on se demande s'il
est utile est ce qu'il faudrait pas tout
simplement le supprimer il ya un article
25 dans le projet de loi séparatisme qui
est très proche de cet article 24
est-ce que c'est nécessaire d'avoir deux
articles presque laquelle la question se
pose exactement dans les termes que vous
évoquez car effectivement il ya une
polarisation sur sa patrie 24 qui était
une modification de la loi de 1881 sur
la liberté de la presse et que l'on peut
se poser la question de savoir si le
droit positif actuel pénale ne répond
pas en tout ou partie à la question et
si si ça n'est que partielle à ce moment
là il faut envisager peut-être de
renforcer l'arsenal pénal de manière de
manière marginale ou de manière vous
manière beaucoup plus importante et ça
ce sont des questions qui se posent mais
font encore une fois on doit avoir un
débat serein et avec marc flores nous
avons un débat serein avec nos
interlocuteurs juste d'autant que le
projet de loi sur le séparatisme doit
vraisemblablement être examinée avant la
deuxième lecture
enfin avant votre lecture de l'article
24 de la loi sur l'eau sécurité globale
ça serait mieux pour vous ça nous n'en
savons rien mais d'abord cette ce texte
de sécurité global d'une proposition de
loi donc il vient de nos collègues
députés
ils n'ont pas de gouvernement alors tout
cas pas officiellement
et il n'a pas été soumis au fossé d'état
il n'a pas été soumis à la keel tandis
que le projet de loi que vous évoquez
qui est celui sur le séparatisme plus
comment l'appeler mais disait disons sur
le séparatisme qui permet de
ce sera donc plus bordé juridiquement
voulait dire je l'espère donc donc nous
on arrive ici on ne fait pas la poésie
ont fait du droit donc l'important c'est
d'avoir des textes qui soit applicable
par les magistrats sur le terrain et que
ce soit dès que la loi soit intelligible
qu'elles soient compréhensibles par les
français donc sa saison des éléments qui
sont extrêmement importants donc
effectivement on aura peut-être une
perturbation du débat du texte ce
séparatisme à l'assemblée quand le texte
si côté global ne sera pas encore étudié
par le sénat donc faudrait qu'on voit ça
dans les dents les semaines qui viennent
allez on poursuit cette émission avec le
rapport de la commission d' enquête sur
la queue vide à l'assemblée
[Musique]
un rapport accablant pour le
gouvernement les députés de la
république en marche ont refusé de le
voter pour afficher leurs divergences
avec le rapporteur l'est républicain
eric ciotti qui a dénoncé lui un
pilotage défaillant de la crise
sanitaire écoutez le
eric ciotti au micro d' examens à gaza
cinquante trois mille morts en france 16
mine à l'animal de matane allemagne
pardon c'est quatre fois plus et ce
n'est pas un hasard et nous cherchons
des explications nous les avons trouvés
dans le manque d'anticipation et de
préparation à une crise qui dépasse
largement la période de ce gouvernement
d'ailleurs et nous le disons dans le
rapport nous l'avons trouvé aussi une
explication dans une gestion de crise
qui a été très chaotique avec beaucoup
de bureaucratie beaucoup de lourdeurs
administratives qui nous ont fait perdre
du temps précieux notamment pour les
tests
et puis nous avons aussi une situation à
l'hôpital où nous étions sans doute là
encore du fait de raisons structurelles
certainement très ancienne mal préparés
à subir une crise majeure
lui qui avait le sénat a mené en
parallèle ces auditions pour la
commission d'enquêté remettra son
rapport la semaine prochaine le
président la république en marge de la
commission denquête à l'assemblée a
dénoncé lui un rapport partial et
partiel au vue des auditions qui ont pu
être mené ici à au sénat est ce que vous
vous êtes plutôt d'accord avec le
constat d'eric ciotti
en fait quand vous quand vous regardez
le sujet que vous venez de diffuser on
peut plus rien dire en fait soit on ne
fait aucune critique de la gestion de
crise et on peut être accusé d'être
simplement les laquais du pouvoir en
place
soit on formule la moindre critique et
forcément on est dans une logique
d'opposition stérile le parlement c'est
pas ça le parlement son rôle c'est de
contrôler l'action du gouvernement est
de le contrôler pendant la crise or moi
j'suis pas membre de la commission d'
enquête du sénat mais par contre j'étais
membre du comité de suivi de la loi du
23 mars 2020 quand le lol la loi sur
l'état d'urgence et pendant le premier
confignon avec philippe bas à présent la
commission des lois à l'époque nous
avons contrôler l'action du gouvernement
nous avons mené des auditions nous avons
fait venir christophe castaner ici donc
faut bien avoir en tête que les les
les conclusions qu'eric ciotti tir j'ai
pas encore lu son rapport donc je peux
pas vous le commenter mais en tout cas
les conclusions qu'il tire sont de
nature à faire changer les choses
on parle d'une troisième vague serre que
la gestion de crise dans notre pays
c'est une culture qu'on doit retrouver
il ya des choix qui ont été faits qui
peuvent être critiqués et qui sont
critiquable en soi et il sent que ça
c'était pour moi c'est extrêmement
important qu'est ce qu'elle a choisi
problème pour vous est ce que c'est les
masques est ce que c'est les tests est
ce que c'est les ars qui ont été
énormément critiqué notamment par les
élus locaux dans toute cette première
vague alors pour moi il ya la latence de
réalisme de réaction par exemple quand
on pense qu'il y a fallu un mois et demi
pour permettre la commercialisation de
masque en tissu dans les pharmacies je
me dis que dans notre pays on a quand
même une latence administrative qui est
coupable qui est geek est grave et qui
crée des difficultés d'affadir on a
essayé on a confié j'étais moi même
témoin du premier cluster et aux
contamines montjoie et de la gestion par
la rs et la gestion par les restes à ce
moment là a été de 2,2 de bonne qualité
mais quand on passe dans une crise
nationale et que le virus circule
partout dans le pays on continue à voir
confier à l'administration de santé ça à
la dgs et aux ars la gestion de crise
alors qu'on aurait dû avoir une gestion
de crise plus plutôt ministère de
l'intérieur plutôt une crise de type
sécurité civile où on a vraiment du
monde sur le terrain je pense aux
pompiers
lens a des gens qui s'entraînent toute
l'année pour gérer une crise sanitaire
de cette ampleur là on a on à odéon
s'interroge chaussée sur les les
personnes à qui on a confié la gestion
de la crise sur le terrain et là c'est
vrai qu'on peut on peut avoir des
critiques et ses critiques elles sont
saines véritablement incriminé cette
seule majorité on voit bien qu'il ya des
problèmes et notamment sur la
reconstitution de stocks de masques qui
existaient bien avant l'arrivée
d'emmanuel vaincrons mais ça c'est
l'honnêteté du parlement et des
parlementaires de voir que ce qu'on a
fait de l'hôpital public depuis 20 ans
les choix que vous évoquez la décrue à
la suppression du stock de
deux masques qui avait été créé à
l'époque de ma roselyne bachelot tous à
toutes ces questions là elle se pose
bien sûr mais on doit avoir un parlement
qui fonctionne et qui interroge les
personnes qui ont été à même de prendre
des décisions et on voit bien que c'est
pas simple et l'exécutif est dans une
situation qui est compliquée et que les
gens s'amusent à vue il faut être humble
et se dire que ça aurait été pas simple
pour les baux qui n'importe quel
exécutif ben franchement mieux à santé
il a pris un ascendant de décision à un
moment donné et on ne connaissait pas
non plus le veer le très bien le virus
là mais de la manière dont il se prend
donc faut avoir beaucoup d'humilité par
rapport à beaucoup d'humilité par
exemple la haute savoie vous l'avais dit
c'était premier kloster sont encore
aujourd'hui un département qui est
particulièrement touché par la deuxième
vague est ce que n'est au niveau local
et leçons de la première vague n'avait
pas été suffisamment tiré au niveau par
exemple local au niveau de votre
département ce qui avait un problème
non je pense pas parce que le lit est
encore une fois le sur le terrain et je
pense notamment aux collectivités
locales qui ont fait beaucoup
pendant la première vague et pendant la
seconde je pense notamment aux hôpitaux
qui ont jugé qu' on est absorbé la
première vague puis la seconde
chacun a pris de la première vague a
essayé de de l'ag et on voit que si on
est si on compare les courbes de la
première vague et de la seconde mardi
partout en europe elles suivent à peu
près les mêmes les mêmes contours donc
oui la haute savoie et plus touchés mais
vous savez pourquoi
c'est un département qui est dynamique
c'est important auquel frontaliers enfin
départements où il ya beaucoup de
circulation et donc forcément ça se voit
plus qu'ailleurs il ya une stratégie
vaccinale qui a été défini cette semaine
est ce que vous trouvez qu'elle est
bonne
200 millions de doses avec des publics
prioritaires qui ont été choisis est-ce
que ça va dans le bon sens selon vous
j'écoutais le professeur philippe juvin
ce matin et il évoquait le fait qu on
est vacciné 10 millions de français en
un mois contre la grippe
là on est on reparle de 14 millions de
français en trois mois avec les
différents vaccins contre lacko vide et
donc moi je me pose la question aussi de
la vitesse de vaccination parce que si
on veut éviter une fois de meubles
je ne suis pas médecin mais je pense
qu'il faut aller vite au début de
l'année 2000 21 pour vacciner un maximum
de personnes pour how pour atteindre un
taux de vaccination dans le pays qu'ils
soient suffisants et qui permettent
d'empêcher une grande partie de la
troisième vague elle et pour terminer
cette émission l'hommage des
parlementaires à valéry giscard
d'estaing
[Musique]
valéry giscard d'estaing décédé donc
mercredi emmanuel macron a décrété une
journée de deuil national le 9 décembre
les hommages se sont multipliés pour
saluer la mémoire de l'ancien président
de la république notamment dans les deux
chambres vge a été un fervent défenseur
du parlement et a été à l'origine de
réformes qui ont renforcé les pouvoirs
de l'opposition jeremy hinzman au nom du
sénat tout entier je souhaite rendre
hommage dans notre hémicycle un homme
d'état au parcours exceptionnel qui a
profondément transformé notre pays c'est
un hommage à la modernité de valéry
giscard d'estaing rendu par gérard
larcher ce jeudi la veille dans
l'hémicycle roselyne bachelot salue et
déjà l'héritage laissé par l'ancien
président valéry giscard d'estaing c'est
le droit à l'avortement c'est
l'abaissement de la majorité civile
c'est le divorce par consentement mutuel
c'est en fait l'auteur de nombreuses
réformes novatrices
parmi ces innovations l'une d'elles
marque un tournant chez les
parlementaires la réforme
constitutionnelle du 29 octobre 1974
quelle en est l'objet c'est de permettre
à un certain nombre de parlementaires
députés et sénateurs de demander au
conseil constitutionnel de vérifier si
une loi est bien conforme à la
constitution
un pouvoir donner à 60 députés ou 60
sénateurs et jusque là réservé au
président de la république au premier
ministre et aux présidents des deux
assemblées
le conseil constitutionnel était en
réalité jusqu'en 1974 plus un conseil
entre guillemets auprès du gouvernement
qu'un conseil qui avait un vrai pouvoir
d'intervention sur l'ensemble des textes
c'est une avancée démocratique et
juridique importante et ça participe à
ancrer la démocratie dans notre pays
autre avancée pour le parlement et
notamment pour l'opposition la création
des questions au gouvernement
ce mode direct de l'accusé je le trouve
même s'il est peut être un peu perdu en
puissance par rapport à avant je le
trouve quand même quelque chose d'assez
important dans notre vie et dans nos
semaine parlementaire je sais pas s'il
serait ravi de voir que maintenant on en
a
quelle dure deux heures d'ailleurs c'est
parfois c'est parfois c'est moins suivie
par les députés malheureusement attaché
au bicamérisme valéry giscard d'estaing
est aussi le seul président à être
intervenu au sénat en 1975 alors valéry
giscard d'estaing est un monument pour
la famille centriste à laquelle vous
appartenez
finalement avec lui c'est la seule fois
où un centriste est vraiment parvenu à
être à la tête de l'exécutif vous qu'est
ce que vous retenez lui ses fondateurs
de l'udf donc ses fondateurs de la
famille politique telle qu'elle existe
encore un peu aujourd'hui vous là vous
avez raison de le rappeler tam mai mais
moi je retiens les grandes évolutions
sociales et sociétales et l'héritage
européen
valéry giscard d'estaing s'est notamment
pour le droit des femmes vous savez que
je siège de la délégation par des femmes
est un aiguillon a rendu un hommage dès
qu'on a appris son sa disparition ce
sont des choses très importantes c'est
aussi la majorité 18 ans et donc moi je
garde du président giscard que j'ai eu
l'occasion de rencontrer mon cheminement
80 donc je sais c'est la fin de son bout
de son mandat de son septennat mai mais
j'ai eu l'occasion de le rencontrer et
de deux voiles à 2,2 me rendre compte de
son intelligence de sa vivacité d'esprit
finit jamais été sénateur mais par
contre il a il avait un attachement
bicamérisme et à cette maison qu'il
avait un attachement à mon département
parce que madame giscard d'estaing d
origine dans en haute savoie et pour les
quatre ans de son élection il est venu
en haute savoie
dans un village de montagne le reposoir
il a toujours gardé voilà un attachement
très fort au monde rural aux français
cette année on a peu caricaturée cette
mère dont il allait aussi dit mais
c'était aussi une volonté commune sans
doute le premier à 7 dans cette
dimension là la française il a aussi
cassé la gueule ou rtf donc c'était
aussi une des libertés important pour
les journalistes que vous êtes d'avoir
une capacité aussi de d'expression
qu'est qui n'était pas aussi évidente
avant donc c'est un un président de
rupture et je constate qu'aujourd'hui
tout le monde devient un peu giscardien
où tout le monde se rappelle dans sa vie
propre personnel ce que le président
giscard a pu changer dans la réalité des
choses et donc ça c'est c'est quelque
chose qui est assez assez émouvant il
laisse un apport important à la
démocratie aussi ont parlé des questions
au gouvernement
la saisine du conseil constitutionnel
dans la vie parlementaire et donc la
réforme de 74 et une réforme extrêmement
importante les questions d'actualité au
gouvernement c'est une manière de
contrôler le gouvernement
d'ailleurs c'est extrêmement au suivi et
on voit bien le mardi à l'assemblée le
mercredi au sénat sont des moments aussi
de tensions entre les deux pouvoirs le
légiste y fait l'exécutif
et puis cette saisine du conseil
constitutionnel par 60 députés ou par 60
sénateurs qui est utilisé très
régulièrement moi ça m est arrivé depuis
six ans que je suis dans cette dans
cette maison d'avoir pu saisir le
conseil constitutionnel avec certains de
mes collègues pour avec vérifier oui les
textes qui ont été censurés la
proposition de loi via la proposition de
loi d'ailleurs le brunch iv sur les
mesures de sûreté pour les ventes en
berne
exactement de choses très important
parce que ça permet d'opérer un contrôle
constitutionnel et de réserver son
parlement soixante députés ou 60
sénateurs c'est peu quand vous raisonnez
en il ya 9 125 députés et sénateurs en
france c'est peu finalement que 60
députés ou 60 sénateurs puissent saisir
le conseil constitionnel donc c'est un
droit supplémentaire qui est aussi
utilisé par les groupes minoritaires et
d'opposition c'est plus de pouvoir à
l'opposition ses amis de lui aujourd'hui
aussi absolument dans le conte est ce qu
est le nôtre on parlait de de la loi
sécurité globale daloa séparatisme vous
imaginez que ces lois
en tout cas l'une d'entre elles n'a pas
été soumise au conseil d'état n'a pas
été soumise à la cnil
pas encore en tout cas ça va l'être mais
on
à cette capacité après le vote par le
parlement d'avoir un contrôle avant que
le président applique le promu la loi
est-ce qu emmanuel macron le fils
spirituel de valéry giscard d'estaing
il ya des trains qui sont qui sont assez
proches après c'est très difficile pour
des personnes de ma génération la
génération du présent la république
puisque présent à payer 60 18 mois
jusqu'à 80 de comparer des gens qui sont
la génération n'ont pas de nos parents
mais de nos grands-parents allant
jusqu'à c'est plutôt les rations de nos
grands parents ont donc cessé c'est très
difficile mais sur un certain nombre de
points on a une sensibilité
peut-être que prétend la république
actuel n'a pas le même attachement au
parlement que le président giscard et
bien merci merci beaucoup loïc hervé
d'avoir été notre invité merci beaucoup
brigitte merci à vous de nous avoir
suivi on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro de
parlement hebdo
[Musique]